hello I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report that's right you got the place
right now time to get educated
max we're gonna talk about dead meat
walking this is Sears you and I haven't
talked about this for many years because
Eddie Lampert a hedge fund manager
bought Sears many years ago and he
turned it into a hedge fund basically a
private equity fund in which he
extracted equity from Sears for many
years Sears used to be one of the
biggest manufacturer retail outlets in
America perhaps the biggest for a while
and now it is going to be no more dead
meat walking why Sears will be
liquidated bankruptcy can only
restructure debts it cannot revive
mutilated brands and bring back mauled
customers this follows the script of the
brick-and-mortar meltdown of retailers
that were bought by Wall Street and
subsequently subjected to asset
stripping and cost-cutting which ruined
what little was left of their brands
mired down in survival mode those
retailers failed to build a vibrant
online presence and fulfillment
infrastructure as sales withered and
losses ravaged the company debts became
unmanageable but the bankruptcy of Sears
Holdings is just so much richer and the
restructuring in bankruptcy has a zero
chance of succeeding before you have a
response to that I want to show you this
chart this is the store count which is
on track to zero from 2011 down down
down well when Eddie Lampert did is all
Sears Kmart mergers he was worth three
to four billion dollars Jeff Bezos at
the time was worth approximately a
billion dollars and I think he made the
comment that Bezos couldn't possibly
compete of course now Bezos is worth one
hundred and fifty two hundred and sixty
billion dollars and eighty Lampert's net
worth has dropped below a billion
dollars the I he was loud 'add in the
financial press as the new warren
buffett at the time ember that i made
the comment at the time that this was
not going to be the case because warren
buffett's empires based on berkshire
hathaway an insurance company which is
the numbnuts way to make a lot of money
if you just stay honest which is almost
impossible and the insurance or banking
industry in ninety
9% or dishonest but Warren Buffett has
just managed to stick to the Knitting
over there at Berkshire Hathaway and
just crank got lots of money and then he
uses those that cash to buy huge stakes
in companies like coca-cola and Apple
Computer etc and that's how he built his
empire Eddie Lampert try to base his
empire on a junk retailer and Kmart
retailer so right from the get-go I
predicted this was would fail and I was
correct more than that Sears did have a
huge brand name I remember getting the
Sears catalog growing up and this was so
exciting and I would spend hours as a
child going through the Sears catalog
and it was so magical and well this
place at all these washing machines and
beds and clothes and shoes and toys and
you got to look through it
Sears itself also was founded in like
nineteen before 1900 and it had some
amazing real estate assets and that's
what's Eddie Lampert was after he'd sold
those off and you'll find out basically
to himself another entity he owned so he
don't weep for him he you know on paper
he might have gone down to a billion
dollars a net worth but he has these
assets which I'm sure will become worth
more soon over the last several years we
have worked hard to transform our
business and unlock the value of our
assets hedge fund owner and Sears
Holdings CEO Eddie Lampert said with
deadpan sarcasm he his hedge fund ESL
and related entities are Sears Holdings
largest shareholders and largest
creditors and what they have lent the
company is secured by the company's best
assets so the value of our assets that
he has unlocked has already gone or will
go to him and ESL you and I were
recently in the Sears in the past year
it was bleak it was Soviet like it was
every all the workers were basically not
motivated they were very unmotivated you
couldn't find any help we walked around
hello hello is anybody here and this was
intentional because he already owned the
best assets there was no reason for him
to invest in any qualified workers for
any building any brands he already had
the best asset
why you do anything more reminds me of
Sir Philip green in the UK with Arcadia
group where he made some acquisitions
and then stripped out a billion pounds
worth of equity in his wife's name in
Monaco and then you know left the
Arcadia group enormous ly indebted
causing problems now Eddie Lampert is
similarly of course being the largest
owner and creditor at the same time
another one of these things that used to
be illegal in America but through the
lobbying efforts and of Wall Street over
the years it's become legal and what the
consequence is being pretty predictable
where you end up with asset strippers
and narrow D Wells like Eddie Lampert
simply stripping assets and pocketing a
lots of money even though his business
acumen as a businessman is provably
quite poor in fact Wall Street goes into
bake basically how he got around the
look back clauses that could deal with
fraudulent conveyance so why why
obviously Sears has been a dead man
walking for years so why did he wait all
these years to finally declare
bankruptcy right now they're gonna go
through basically keep in operation
through Christmas
this is goodwill it's supposed to
achieve because you're gonna keep these
jobs through Christmas we're gonna care
about the American population so they're
they now have a debtor-in-possession
loan of 300 million dollars mostly
coming from Eddie Lampert but one of the
ways for Lampert to get their real
estate is to pledge it as collateral for
a loan and then have the company default
on the loan another way is this Sears
holding already sold two hundred and
thirty five of its best stores for 2.7
billion dollars in sweetheart deals to
Sara tidge Growth Properties when it was
still a Sears entity some of them on a
leaseback basis Sara tidge was then spun
off from Sears via a rice offering in
July 2015
Lampert is chairman of Sara tidge and
owns a big chunk of it via the Wrights
offering aggrieved investors in Sears
Holden filed suit and 2017 Sears
Holdings in Lampert
for forty million dollars so in July
2015 there's a two-year look-back clause
for fraudulent conveyance so he
basically took this property first he
sold it to Sears a Sears Holding then
took over that Sears holding all in his
own name so now we're past the two years
where he you know well past of two years
for him to basically not have any
confrontation with shareholders in court
once again in a property market offering
huge ways to avoid accountability and
Taxation we covered the story of course
with the Trump Jared cushion Jared
Kushner making hundreds of millions of
dollars with real estate scams and Eddie
Lampert real estate scammer but the
reason why this keeps going is because
the banking industry is the lenders into
this scammy market and so they are the
top lobbyists in Washington they they
populate the legislative branch so they
constantly are they're changing the laws
or passing new laws to make this type of
scam a property nightmarish developer
illegal or they can get away with it
so until you get rid of those lobbyists
in DC there's nothing gonna stop this
speaking of lobbyists in DC Saudi Arabia
spends more than any other nation on
earth probably any more than any
corporation on earth and lobbying and
because of their lobbying they have a
lot of goodwill in America despite
accidentally torturing to death some
journalists who they then dismembered
accidentally and flush them down the
toilet so here's a headline speaking of
dead man walking endeavour pulling out a
four hundred million dollar Saudi Arabia
deal endeavour is a talent agency and in
Hollywood owned by Ari Emanuel who is
Rahm Emmanuel's brother
well endeavor is trying to extricate
itself from a deal with the Saudi
government to invest four hundred
million dollars into the company The
Hollywood Reporter has learned the move
comes as pressure mounts for Hollywood
to take a stand against the Kingdom in
the wake of the disappearance and
possible murder of Saudi journalist
Jamal Khashoggi who wrote for The
Washington Post
at the time of this article written it
was a you know basically he was
disappeared but here I want to point out
that all
these companies by the way Saudi Arabia
also finances much of Silicon Valley
they're huge they're the number one
investor actually as outside investors
in startups there they basically are
huge investors in the Atlantic Council
which then gets to determine whether or
not you the ordinary citizen in America
whether your content is allowable to be
posted on Facebook since since they
accidentally murdered and dismembered a
journalist they are also still in charge
of basically eradicating wiping out
memory holing thousands of Americans
activist groups like say they they took
down like fifteen hundred anti you know
basically cop watchdog groups that look
at cop murders and misdeeds all those
have been eradicated so you know by the
Atlantic Council who are financed partly
by Saudi Arabia the thing about Saudi
Arabia is they is the oil as a weapon
you know if they get too close to
investigating what's going on over there
they push the price of oil up now on
last ten years because of fracking in
America America positioned itself as
energy independent and no longer subject
to the political pressures that can be
borne upon them from OPEC and the Saudis
so we're gonna see a real test of this
because all of the the litany of Horrors
coming out of Saudi Arabia is making
people puke I mean if Hollywood which
would you know not known for their
cultural sensitivity not known for their
you know selectivity when it comes to
taking money let's say if they're not
taking Saudi money that would indicate
that Saudis are having trouble finding
buyers of their lies anywhere in the
Western Hemisphere so so but so they try
to push the oil you know have used the
oil as a weapon this would be a real
test of America's frakkers first of all
they did threaten to use oil as a weapon
but obviously things are
cooling down memories are very short
Hollywood is better than anybody at
propaganda at basically they could do
not zero dark thirty which was a
oscar-winning film I think that
basically made our our own actions of
torture and accidental murder in
accidental murder in Iraq heroic here
they could do zero dark Istanbul they
could create a sort of homage to MBS you
know Mohammed bin Salman he had already
met and been fetid in Hollywood had
dinner at Rupert Murdoch's house all the
bigwigs of Hollywood were there I'm sure
he's got plenty of money
MBS meets Rocky I mean what an epic film
this would be you know there is the
plucky Saudi royal take yeah the plump
Saudi royal fighting the truth and for
the price of oil not to go up oh I'm
just waiting for this this is gonna be
epic but we must wait a little bit
longer because a break is happening now
and then it will be back with rocky -
very exciting film in development now
don't go away
welcome back to the Kaiser report on
Mexico their time now to return to
Alistair McLeod in the UK talking about
his latest report the credit cycle is on
the turn Alistair welcome back max I'm
going to quote a little bit from your
piece and it says here that the world's
total government non-financial corporate
and consumer debt increase from 64
trillion in 2000 to 105 trillion in 2008
you say today is probably 186 trillion
you know in 1971 we rolled up our debts
into the new all fiat dollar and this
has set the stage for what you think
could be a reversal in the credit cycle
and interest rates starting to go up the
cycle is turning and I would imagine
this would have an impact on the gold
market alistair tell us about it what's
interesting about this max is that I
have seen this before I saw I saw this
when I was a young stockbroker back in
the early 70s and that it was
particularly in the UK at that time the
rate of inflation went from something
like five or six percent up to a high of
24 percent at the same time as that was
happening the gold price went up from
$35 to what eventually it ended up on
one fix at 850 dollars which was a 24
times multiplication so I mean the
important point as far as gold is
concerned is that the idea that rising
interest rates is bad for gold is not
right and the reason it's not rise is
very very simple if you look at physical
gold you're actually comparing it with
cash physical cash and if you're looking
at futures and options then you're
looking at least rates and things like
that there is an interest rate on gold
if you want to lend it but basically the
idea that higher interest rates is bad
for gold is completely wrong if anything
higher interest rates because they
reflect increasing price inflation is
good for gold the currency if it if it
loses confidence you have a
of confidence in the currency and
interest rates are going up to try to
restore confidence the market can
sometimes react very negatively to that
as we've seen in Venezuela Argentina in
other countries you have a full-blown
currency crisis and so interest rates
are immaterial in that in that
environment because people want to just
have something that's not going wildly
into the Garbage Pail and they turn to
gold now as the dollars been rising
Alistair emerging market currencies
especially in the Argentina's peso and
the Turkish lira they have been selling
off quite heavily do you expect a debt
crisis emerging in even more profound
ways in these emerging economies could
this be I guess the bigger picture here
is it could this be the pin that if
pulled becomes like the subprime crisis
it becomes the the the the touch paper
of an of the financial crisis that's
just coming into the for today Alistair
I think not basically the the emerging
markets problem problems are problems
for the emerging market and its currency
mismanagement is the economic
mismanagement everything you like I
think the point that you touched on
which is absolutely vital is to
understand that the relationship between
money and prices is twofold first of all
we all know as monetarists will tell us
that if you increase the quantity of
money then you're going to increase
price inflation but there is another
thing and that is with a fiat currency
it depends far more on confidence in
that currency if people begin to lose
confidence in the currency which is
what's happened in Venezuela then
basically there is no hope for the
currency it goes down the pan and it
doesn't matter what interest rates what
anyone does while that situation happens
the currency has had it it's exactly the
same thing that happened to the Jewish
walk or the son took the mark in 1923 so
I would say that it is the same problem
but it's not its origin if you like as
far as the door is concerned will not be
from emerging
you have this unpalatable message going
out there that confidence in the u.s.
dollar could be in a critically waning
endgame if you will and this is not a
message people want to hear and it just
seems that it's almost impossible to
envision a situation where the Fed can't
come to the rescue
you know when it comes to forcing
countries to accept dollars and to
accept being the buyer of first and last
resort of American debt you know the US
has always relied on the military for
that you know when the countries tried
to get out of the dollar what could be
Iraq could be Iran could be Russia could
be China you know they start
saber-rattling so the u.s. still has a
huge military doesn't this give them
some protection Alastor not really
because you know the real problem if you
like on that scale isn't isn't Libya and
Gadhafi it's not Iraq and Saddam Hussein
is China and China all says I mean if
you look at China on a PPP basis your
purchasing power parity basis it is
already larger than the US and in terms
of this of this economy the is actually
nothing that the Americans can do to
stop the if you like the the the yuan
superseding the dollar as the currency
of trade throughout Asia and so the
dollar effectively has lost that story
and this is the problem you know they
can't force it anymore
there is a parallel that I would like to
draw to your attention max and that is
if you go back to when the London gold
pool failed in the late 1960s the reason
it failed was because there were too
many dollars abroad outside America as a
result of the Vietnam War and before
that it was the result of the Korean War
that was all financed by dollars which
were just exported and given that it was
the old French Indochina where Vietnam
was it was France that ended up with an
awful lot of dollars France said we
don't want dollars any
more we're going to redeem them for gold
which they were entitled to do under the
Bretton Woods Agreement that was a major
turning point when it came to the dollar
I think that we're facing a similar
situation today obviously things are the
circumstances are very different but
you've got all these dollars as I was
referring to earlier which are in
foreign ownership you have got China
which is taking over the world economy
as it were in terms of kraid anyway
fighter has already got the whole of
sub-saharan Africa in his pocket it is
spending money in Latin America it is
spending and money even around the
Caribbean it's extraordinary how far
China's tentacles have gone it is doing
exactly what America did in the 1950s
and 1960s and America what's their
response their responses make America
great
by becoming introspective I mean they're
trying to sort of them isolate
themselves if you like from the rest of
the world and so the there's any one way
for the dollar to go and the lesson was
what happened way back in 1967 yeah we
might be kind of isolationist and all
that but at least we're not trying to
brakes it anyway I'll stir you know
you're talking about China depolarizing
and I think one of the obvious kind of
tell-tale signs there is that they've
been hoarding gold they've been buying
gold hundreds of tons I think they've
been preparing for the day when they
need to walk away from the dollar and
also they've been encouraging Chinese
people to hoard gold so any consequences
that might suffer from a dollar collapse
will be made up for locally in the
Chinese community in China by the fact
that they own lots and lots of gold I
want to skip ahead to for the first time
Saudi Arabia has threatened to use oil
as a weapon okay this harkens back to
the 1970s now this after they
accidentally tortured a journalist to
death quote-unquote and then chop them
into pieces by accident apparently does
this threat mean anything should we
monitor this
dowdy back in the news I'll stir well
obviously we do have to monitor it and
but at the moment everybody's trying to
get into damage limitation mode I think
it's going to be very difficult for this
one to be brushed off in the same way as
you know the traditional Oh with the
spies or the you know the intelligence
Department fouled up I mean that
basically is the story that they're
trying to push every time that you know
an intelligence department is caught
murdering someone then you know that is
the story the state produces it's not
believable is the short answer and it
seems to me that there is even more
evidence to come out of the Turkish
government hands because there's tear
they bugged the consulate which
incidentally is a vet is an invasion of
diplomatic privacy but that I think it's
a story that is gonna get worse before
it gets better
and it has enormous consequences I think
for MBs Mohammed bin Salman I don't know
how they get out of that because Saudi
Arabia is such a controlled place I mean
you know the leadership control
everything the idea that the leadership
was not aware of what was going on in
the the consulate in Istanbul I mean it
just doesn't wash it all
they are control freaks in that country
well let me ask you this question I'll
go off script for a second because I
know you're over there in the UK and you
therefore would be watching the BBC is
the BBC covering what's happening in
with the Saudi scandal with the same
vigor that they've been covering Russia
the so-called Russia gate phenomenon
Alastair I think that probably giving it
less tension but that is probably
because brexit is dominating the news
here what I would say is that in Frank
Gardner who's their Middle East
correspondent and security correspondent
they have got an extremely good man and
his reports are credible and worth
listening to and it is absolutely clear
from what he says that this is a story
which
is extremely unfortunate extremely
difficult for everybody concerned and we
haven't heard the end of it getting back
to kind of Saudi in the US and the
petrodollar and you know Trump said
something to the effect of we're gonna
give the Saudis the benefit of the doubt
because after all we sells up 120
billion dollars at the farms every year
and so we in those that means a lot of
jobs and you know Trump has been very
good so far
in couching everything in terms of jobs
and growth and stock market growth do
you think that that dog will hunt
as they say in the south do you think
that old that'll go over it's a
difficult one to know I mean it comes in
a bit of a difficult position here
because he's got the midterm elections
coming up and I think he's got his eye
on that more than anything else so
anything he says I think is with a view
to not jeopardizing the Republicans
prospects in the midterms sorry let me
let me just jump in because they've got
about less than a minute so I just want
to summarize kind of your report here
let draw people's attention to it they
should look this up the credit cycle is
on the turn Alister MacLeod is the
author it's a major piece in my view
because he may else there may be the
only economist in the world to actually
call the turn in the bond market after
almost everyone else has failed and
doing so interest rates are on the rise
and that the reason being that inflation
which has been hidden through hedonic
adjustments and bad financial reporting
can't be hidden anymore and once the
inflation genies out of the bottle then
you're entering a new cycle of higher
rates do you agree with that Alister I
agree with that yes I mean I some
slightly more complex than that but
that's the essence of it well I mean if
they want the complex version they can
listen to the whole freakin interview
anyway we got a go thanks for being on
the Kaiser report that was my pleasure
that's gonna do it for this edition of
the Kaiser report with me max Kaiser and
Stacy Herbert like to thank our guest
alistair McLeod of gold money.com if you
want to reach us on twitter you can do
so Kaiser report or download the RT app
and watch our show on your phone that's
not a great idea
until next time bye y'all
[Music]